luna the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin
if you're just getting into crypto it's the
perfect place to start hey guys and welcome back
to the la hile pan show powered by icon plus
capital the visa the vc firm and sponsored by
blockfi you can get 250 when you sign up if you
find the link somewhere and everywhere joining
me today is ben askren ben how you doing
i'm doing good i'm just on vacation with my family
right now we're in northern wisconsin so i did
this yesterday the internet worked i'm hoping it
works again i'm a little bit nervous but uh let's
do it no i think it's gonna be good i watched your
show yesterday um and you had a pretty interesting
chat so i'm gonna push you on a few things let's
go yeah i'm excited but it's been i think nearly a
year since we last spoke you were the third guest
on my podcast um so i feel like it's quite it's
quite um like poetic you know like doing it a year
later yeah absolutely i i'm gonna say we're gonna
have you back on our show because uh you got a
book coming out so i'm excited to read that and
then we'll have to have you on and chat about your
book yeah no i'm honestly so bad but what have you
been up to since we last spoke i know you were
working on a couple different things i think you
launched um you launched a course like a year ago
but what are you working on at the moment uh man i
got my main thing with my wrestling academy is we
have five of them in the state of wisconsin here
um for those of you who don't know that's like
north of chicago uh for you people in the uk
my main my my main focus uh we also have podcasts
so i podcast flow wrestling we do the crypto
show on tuesdays uh and like i said right now
i'm on a family vacation so everything's good
and last time we spoke you were saying how you
were helping people get into crypto by sort of
giving like paying them in bitcoin to kind of give
you know so they don't have to buy it how's that
going especially the wrestling academy have you
been able to get more people involved oh the kids
so it was it was the guys who worked at my house
last summer and then oh yeah they love me because
they're all college kids and you know so they made
like we'll say they made 800 a thousand bucks but
i paid them a bitcoin so you know at that point
it was i don't know we'll say somewhere between
eight nine thousand dollars likely you know we're
talking july june july 2020. um so most those guys
made like seven thousand dollars or six thousand
dollars you know for them they were really pumped
that is amazing that is amazing what about the
wrestling academy are you able to get anyone else
involved no i didn't pay anything with bitcoin
because i'm not the sole owner there uh but it
was mostly just those guys you know what's really
funny i i know you talk a lot about crypto layout
i got one i think only one person to buy under the
old all-time high of twenty thousand dollars uh i
why i convinced one person to buy it like march 13
march 14 when the when the crash happened in 2020
and then after 20 thousand dollars i probably
had 12 to 15 people buy and it's like none of
that it was just they were just so scared
before 20 000. they're oh it's only 8
10 whatever and then after that there's been
a lot they've bought um most of them are still
in the green because most of them bought you
know once a hit they're like oh this is safe
and they bought it say between 25 and 30. uh but
i did have some friends buy it you know 45.50
and then obviously you know the dip happened they
got nervous and now they've been on the first
roller coaster ride so i think they're going
to be in for good see they didn't panic sell
uh if they did they didn't admit it to me
fair enough but you know what gets me so
there are so many really cool things in this space
whether it be just you know like making gains you
know hedging against inflation but like so many
cool products like bitcoin cashback for example
like i use coin coin in coin corner in the uk
and i'm trying to get my personal trainer to
um start using these things and she won't do it
like i don't understand why people just won't do
it it's so life-changing you could just like get
eight percent you know cash back even you know
whether it's crypto.com when you use these cards
people are so afraid like they think it's too good
to be true do you find that yeah uh hmm i think
it's more just uh people are scared of change
people are scared of something new our thought
it requires them to learn something so i also
i have gotten my i haven't put this out but i got
my block fight card also oh it's great i get cash
back um i've put some of the crypto over there
to kind of try it out i'm playing with uniswap
now that's kind of scary because that i still
don't totally get it i starting to get it uh
but that's hard yeah so there's a lot of these
mechanisms in crypto right now uh who rewards
you like i guess we'll say like banks used to
reward you right if we go uh 50 uh 80 100 years
back banks actually rewarded their savers and
now banks don't reward their savers i think the
interest rate on a savings account is like
point zero five percent or something just
it's not something i i know i had someone call me
from a bank recently and because i don't know why
they shouldn't have access but they saw that i had
a large balance and they said well you shouldn't
put in a checking account you should put a savings
account i said what what's the interest they said
it's like point zero point six or something i'm
like well you realize how like nothing that is
did you wait you said that to them it's nothing
i don't care i don't i don't need your point six
percent or whatever [ __ ] you're trying to
give me like if you were gonna give me five
percent i'd consider but you're not so get
lost what did they say when you said that
i think i think it was very short conversation
they didn't have anything else just you know
when you're when you're giving a sales pitch
on something you want to be able to you know
fill the customer's questions and when i say don't
you have anything better than point six percent or
maybe it was even it might have even been less
than that it might have been like point four i
don't recall exactly um they didn't have anything
else better to offer so i should not get lost
you know yeah good it's negative interest rates
across europe so yeah this is why i say to people
you know get involved and they just don't do it
um but it's been a crazy week with the markets
um i know you mainly talk about bitcoin but i
really just want to delve into this and understand
you know how diversified you
really are um you retweeted my ada
yeah you retweeted my ada tweet the are you are
you an ada holder i bought ada at eight cents
ain't good to me did you buy like a good amount is
it are you is it life changing now i wouldn't say
it's very nice i wouldn't say life changing um
but yeah it's a good amount um the other thing
is that you're really nice about ada and i
didn't really so i bought it on etoro when
i was working with them and uh they just
stake it for me so i've been getting like
i don't know for a long time 50 60 more eta per
month or somewhere in there you know so now it's
like it's you know i probably got a thousand
two thousand i don't say free ada but like
that i didn't buy right it's free essentially
right i staked it and they gave me more so
um yes that's really nice what else are you
holding um but you know what i just bought
on john kim's advice uh we've had tyler on the
show a couple times he's really really smart
um i and so you know i said hey you know what john
i trust you let's go for it i bought some of that
uh i've had eth for a very long time
i've had litecoin for a very long time
i i told you this i got burned in 2017 because i
bought some of the like [ __ ] coin icos then with
the zero so i have tried to be more diligent about
what i invested and the majority of this it varies
probably 80 bitcoin 70 bitcoin something like
that but like hey i'll throw a couple thousand
dollars on here five thousand dollars on
there just for fun just see how it goes
and um you know a couple of them have done really
well what did you i remember you saying that you
had a really rocky ride in 2017 was it like 50k
you lost or something remind me oh probably not
so i probably put in and probably the end of 2017
i probably put in around fifty thousand dollars
um because at that point point basically allowed
me to put in like it was something ridiculous it
was only like four thousand dollars a week so i
have to wait till actually at that point if you
remember it was going on everything was going
like this you know so it's like if i could have
got it in in august versus probably took me until
november or something to get it in it would have
been much nicer i just i didn't buy enough bitcoin
right i bought bitcoin i bought my coin i bought
ethereum but then i bought a bunch that went
to zero i bought um oh veritasium went to zero
uh pillar is close to zero or something out
of it zero so yeah so i did i probably lost
we would let's say between twelve and twenty
thousand dollars on projects that went to zero
that's probably a fair guess so how are you
picking your projects now other than john kim's uh
recommendation majority of it's bitcoin
um yeah you know i think that's now been
established and when i tell new people to get
into it i just just buy bitcoin it's simple
it's been around forever it's safe it's safe
and it still has some pretty good upside um
and then you know a lot of it i bought
luckily i had a bunch of cash sitting around
in march of 2020 when everything went down you
know still like i got a theorem at 170 i got
ate at eight cents you know i bought a lot of
these projects when everything because i was
i've been following them at that point and then
this crash happened and i'm like oh crap like
we're never gonna see pro my thing was we're
never going to see prices this low this is like
the lordness and i think i believe that has
been true with almost everything so i bought
a lot of things back then so yeah i guess
in 2021 i would say it's like bitcoin um
i bought a tiny bit of uni unit swap and link
just for fun well i think those categories are
like there is going to be a d5 exchange that's
going to be totally insanely huge right and
unisoft leading the way there's going to be
an oracle that's totally insanely huge and
do you ever get um you're obviously quite
diversified so do you ever get wrapped up
in like bitcoin maximalism or like you
just like brush that stuff off you know
i just i i mean i know the a lot of people do
bitcoin i know they're really smart i know they're
really really and i know as far as uh crypto they
were they had more knowledge than me 100 of that
but just the fact that there could only
be one i i don't get it and the other
thing about that is you only need to have
one counter example to prove them wrong
because once they're wrong they're wrong you know
and they so like i just don't see and i know a few
of them kind of got on me but i i don't see how
you can accomplish some of the things that these
other products accomplish with just bitcoin i just
don't feel like it can be done um and you know
the one i that i've worked a lot with is the ray
token which is a very small project at this point
um but it supplies the rockford network and
essentially the raid token represents the value of
the rockfin network and if you were to put bitcoin
in place it just wouldn't have the same effect
so i just don't get the bitcoin maximalism
yeah like here's my thing i i look at it as
like social media networks they're all sort of
the same you know like you connect you speak to
people you can post pictures you can write things
but then they're not the same and i don't really
think it matters whether we have multiple
ones you can still argue you know bitcoin
is the best store of value bitcoin is the best
technology doesn't mean the others can't exist yes
but it doesn't mean the others can't exist correct
and then one thing that i would say if they said
just this very specific thing um i can agree i
think i can agree with it or again with it more
is that bitcoin is the only one that actually
needs to be a currency right so like ethereum
can be a token that works that network so can
cardano so can rate right these other ones
they can be a token that represents things within
that network um that don't necessarily we need to
be dollars right we need to be currently um
whereas bitcoin i think bitcoin is now i tell
everyone to be that it's gonna be the greatest
currency humans have ever invented no i'm with
you like to me this time that always gets thrown
around in the community is bitcoin is sound money
and it is and nobody's necessarily arguing
well there are people but i don't think you
and i arguing that um yeah yeah but i don't think
you and i are arguing that like if this sounds
money and it's gonna you know be the the global
reserve currency it's just not about that but um
i'd love to hear your thoughts on the markets
because today it's a little bit of a red day um
welcome to we're at because it moves so fast you
know i i need to check i haven't checked you need
to check okay well we're at 48k it didn't hold 50.
um everything seems to be relatively down today
um do you have a strategy going on or are you just
like a long-term holder like are you going to like
when do you think this bull market is going to
end are you going to cash out to stable coins or
yeah so i am i'm not a trader i and
this is adjacent zombies sometimes for
you at the top you should if you're a
regular person not rich and [ __ ] like jason
selling some will probably impact your life
i'm not saying sell all but i have never sold
anything i haven't sold anything
anything yet so the notion that um
you know i'm like not a bitcoin long-term holder
it's just not true because i i am i've for since
it being i've held everything i've never sold
anything um but i think you know a lot of people
think i feel smarter than me think the top of
the cycle is going to be the end of this quarter
potentially to start quarter one 2022 um and
yes i don't see why you can't take some profits
um and you know maybe listen here's what i argue
too here's what i argued to jason yesterday i said
for some people in the middle class if they bought
a cheap we'll say i bought a five thousand dollar
multiple five thousand bitcoins um when it went
march if it goes up to what a lot of people think
it is uh 200k right if if i sell 20 percent of my
supply mm-hmm that's probably not changing money
to a lot of people so they change their life they
still have 80 they're not selling so if it doesn't
go down right because there isn't we've had this
cyclical nature of bitcoin if it doesn't go down
they still hold 80 percent it goes it goes to
the moon like he says go to a million dollars
great now they have 80 percent of the supply
that's worth now a million dollars which is
started at five which is 200x okay if if it goes
back down right if we see a 50 60 retracement
now they can spend that 20 that they sold they
can spend uh and buy you know 2x 3x of what they
would have held and if it doesn't it goes to
the moon and they're still happy like both
both win so i just i don't see that viewpoint
i think he's maybe been been rich too long
all my friends have a mortgage and if yeah
i understand at age 35 or 36 that would be
life-changing to a lot of my friends and
so like how he doesn't see that viewpoint
um i i just i think some of these people either
they're they're two bitcoin maximalists which
whatever i surprised to love them uh or they're
too rich and they just don't they don't see that
point or i think an alternative thing is like
i think it's just like a branding thing to just
you know publicly constantly say that they'll hold
forever and the thing is i can totally understand
taking profit if you need to like i get that
you're taking profit into like a shitty system
which once you've taken that profit the money
will devalue but if you directly i'm going to
spend it on something whether it's like paying off
a mortgage or if it's you know i don't know buying
your children some stuff because you can't pay
for things in bitcoin yet um and you don't have
anything and you need to buy your kids some food
you know yeah yeah i'm not gonna say hey listen
take your profit and go buy a fancy car i wouldn't
use it don't do that i'll agree i want to pay your
mortgage off or you know even for some people
let's say here let's take this example say they
sell one bitcoin at let's say it gets a 200 grand
okay they want to change out to a stable coin
and they want to go on block five uh and get
i think what do you get eight percent and i'm
doing an advertisement for block five they're not
paid black fight you should be paid me for this
um they get i can do it they pay me it's fine it's
eight point six eight percent okay so on the short
thousand they're gonna make 16 grand a year like
listen for some people uh that's what 1200 extra
dollars a month that that's gonna be really nice
that's going to change their life just having 1200
extra months is coming in so i yeah for middle
class lower class people uh it could definitely
be life-changing stuff yeah i think there isn't
kind of one rule for all and that's like the
narrative that's pushed in the space and i think
it's quite dangerous to be honest um because
when the ball run was going on on clubhouse i was
on clubhouse quite a lot and unfortunately um the
narrative and the advice genuinely the financial
advice that was being said was just smash by
just smash by like we're in the top we're at
the top of a bull market it's like 50k we're
telling these people who you don't know you
don't know their financial situation to smash
by despite bitcoin potentially crashing
down to 20k i mean some of the advice
yeah i i agree fully unless i would never ever
say sell your whole supply but if if vic you own
bitcoin and it goes up and the money is going to
be life-changing to you right and everyone's in a
different financial situation um then then why not
sell why not sell a little bit um and i just i i
can't see the argument to that and obviously
some people on bitcoin are very wealthy
but some people aren't right and so if they
can change their life change their lives
100 like i'm definitely for holding money in
a stable coin and earning interest on that you
know if you can't wait for another cycle
and if you can't wait another four years
um but this week we've also seen some crazy crazy
weird things did you see visa bought a crypto punk
no i didn't see that where was that yeah so visa
bought a crypto punk have over in here for 150 000
i'm gonna say dollars probably it's not gonna be
pounds is that um what do you think do you are you
buying any crypto punks i listen i i did an nfp
oh you did what did you do well uh i did one of my
for my of myself um i did it in april um because
i knew people like jason loves them who i do the
podcast with yeah he loved it i listen i
was i was never an artwork collector um
so maybe that's why i don't get it i don't i don't
understand the i really don't understand the nft
thing um i know a rich people hold money and
artwork i get that what they're gonna do in nfts
i guess it's cool if you're into that
thing i'm just i'm not super into it
i think it i mean okay so i also find it a little
bit strange especially um the whole copy paste
side of things um like bitcoin solves the double
spend problem this obviously doesn't affect that
um you know the copy paste thing just throws
me but i definitely see value in kind of like
digitizing stuff giving it uh you know whether
it's like uh rolexes handbags just to authenticate
it authenticate where it came from you know it's
history that always gives it value um but i think
it's like anything right like everything in
the end goes digital whether it's like art
digital real estate which people are talking
about now um maybe you should buy i might buy
i'll just buy i mean i so i don't like it i don't
fully understand it i don't get the value so i
might as well just buy bitcoin which is something
i understand a whole lot more so i'll just they
can own the nfts i'll just keep buying bitcoin no
i'm with you you shouldn't buy into things which
which you don't fully get but i know i think
i think it's a space which isn't going to die
down i actually heard that facebook um are now
going to get into nfts that was a bit late really
yeah facebook's been flirting with
crypto for forever it feels like i mean
uh oh my gosh what was the name of their wallet i
mean this is back in 20 what 2018. they had libra
yeah so they had libra yes but never really
it kind of happened but not really happened
um and you've been thinking they were going to
get in forever and they haven't the other one
that i'm really interested to see what happens is
apple has all of that extra cash sitting around
so you got to think at some point michael sayler
is going to get into their brain and have them
buy some bitcoin do you think they will they
at the rate the dollars devaluing it's uh it
would be shocking if they didn't diversify
because they have such a large cash supply
and i also had um i just wanted like another
thing that i had so i'm just going through so
many different news points that have come up um
so deloitte did you see this they did this survey
this survey about um covering a bunch of different
financial institutions and they discovered that
76 percent of financial professionals think
that a basket of cryptos like bitcoin xrp ada
will replace the us dollar in at least under
10 years is this just like wishful thinking
yes i did see uh that article um 10 years feels
fast 10 years feels very i mean who knows all
right now when and honestly because on a spectrum
10 years ago was essentially right or give or take
a year or two is that yeah bitcoin and that seems
like eons ago i mean it really does seem like so
long ago so i guess things aren't moving very
quickly but then again there's so much power
wrapped up in the ability to make currency um
it doesn't feel like the world governments are
going to want to give that up so i think maybe you
know we see someone like el salvador who did it
a few other countries start going that
direction because obviously bitcoin is
not devaluing at all whereas the dollar is and so
if they can hold the bitcoin as a reserve currency
maybe then you know i think it's essentially it is
game theory right because then once some countries
do it and other countries have to kind of follow
suit otherwise there will be winners and losers
um but tenure still feels i don't know why that
feels like too fast who knows maybe i could be
wrong yeah i mean the interesting thing about this
entire space is like so much has happened no well
so much but so little has happened in 10 years
in that institutions are now jumping into bitcoin
countries are accepting it but i sort of feel
that it won't be as long i think more will happen
in the next 10 years do you know what i mean
because now like once it happens what it wants
faster than 10 years say that again you think it's
going to happen faster than 10 years that bitcoin
will be a world reserve currency okay so okay
so the thing is i think that that is a huge jump
and i don't know whether that will happen in 10
years necessarily but i think the growth will be
faster than what we saw in the last 10 years just
given how far how quickly it's already happened
and how far we are i don't think you know a lot of
those 10 years were all about legitimacy proving
bitcoin having to prove itself now it's proved
itself the next 10 years could be much faster
yeah i mean it's possible i i yeah i just
have a hard time seeing people who have
power wanting to give up power uh that that's
always a struggle so uh let's go bitcoin but i
man i i'm i if you gave me an over under bet
here right now i would bet the over really
yeah okay we'll have to pick this up but um well i
think it'll happen i'm just gonna bet the over no
fair enough but in terms of your price you always
ask um people on your show for price predictions
so i'm obviously gonna have to have to throw
that back at you sure uh i i would definitely say
it's going to be uh it's gonna be six figures
um i'm starting so i listen i listen to two
people as far as price action and trading is
concerned although you don't trade and that's
nicholas myrna datadash and scott milker the wolf
of all streets i really enjoy both of them um and
nicholas mer's been pushing this it's going to be
so most people think top of this cycle is quarter
four of this year nicholas martin's also pushing
this theory that it might be a longer cycle so
the the top of the cycle might stretch into 2022
somewhere um and it kind of feels like that's a
possibility now right because we had the huge rush
up uh in the early part of this year um and then
we kind of plateaued for a minute there and then
we had the dip and then we chopped sideways for a
while and now we've been steadily climbing up but
it hasn't been like this parabolic move it's been
like it just climbs and climbs and climbs and so i
could definitely see the top not going until 2022
sometime um so i am gonna say it's gonna be six
figures by the end of the year but okay like just
just over um somewhere which i i would probably
if we talked to crippled people i would probably
be on the low end of most people's guesses
you know like john kim my co-host is saying
250k uh that's the high end that's the high end
yeah you think yes well i've heard people say
more i've heard people say other things that are
even more uh but that jason what'd he say i think
he thinks 200k by i want to say he said october
27th i think he did say october 27th i don't know
what number yeah i don't know what number yeah so
um well what do you say i'm obviously i don't i
don't feel comfortable making price predictions
i will say 36 figures by the end of the year um
i don't think it's gonna be much over that
i'm gonna go like kind of on the nicholas
merton line of thought and say that it happens
sometime next year where it fully peaks out
yeah i'm with you i think six figures
by the end of the year apparently
there'll be a big dump in september wait who
said that and then it says so many people
really why what so what's their reasoning
because it's they say that there's going
to be a run-up and then naturally there'll be
a huge correction and then one last spike um
i don't know it it's all just speculation but if
if jason's right in that 20 in the 27th of october
then it makes sense to have a bit of a correction
beforehand um but yeah i'm so excited for this um
i'm trying to get more people involved it's it's
so difficult and it surprises me how difficult it
is um because you feel like we're talking when
we start this conversation we're talking about
like negative interest rates and it always blows
my mind you know and i'm like guys you're leaving
your money and in accounts which make nothing
but um there's so many people who don't don't
even wanna they don't even wanna think about it
is i think that's the biggest issue right oh i'm
don't want to think about it uh they would
rather just kind of do whatever they're doing
on an everyday basis they would much rather watch
if they're a male probably some type of sporting
event they're a female some type of reality show
i know i'm generalizing don't cancel me for that
okay it's totally okay um yeah rather than think
about like and you know i brought this up on the
podcast yesterday with john i can't remember what
point he was making about bitcoin changing his
life and i said to him one of the things that's
really made me think about which i i never really
thought all that much about it previously you know
hey i i was what 31 or 32 when i got into bitcoin
um so what i mean it's like there's number
one great a lot of grifters so i think the
banks are grifters jimmy song makes this point
in his book where they're just pulling money off
the top um in all different kinds of ways and
now bitcoin and crypto allows us to exchange
like i could send you i think i just saw someone
sent 150 billion dollars for four dollars
um what price i just have to finance finance
thank you yeah and so like that can happen right
um yeah if i want to send you cash to
the bank it's gonna take like three days
or four days and it's gonna take 40 bucks or
something like that to send a thousand dollars
um so just inefficient and they're grifting and
so that's one of the huge things that i think
i've been paying attention to since i got into
crypto and the the other one is just oh he went
i'm still here i'm here uh the other thing is just
the uh the moral hazard of countries being able to
print money i mean it's really not good it just
it incentivizes all types of bad behavior again i
guess i'm kind of i've read you guys should read
it jimmy song's book um thank god for bitcoin
um i'm referencing a couple times here but just
to be it's a moral hazard to be able to print
as much money as you want and a lot of people
would even argue that wars wouldn't happen the
way they happened if countries couldn't just
print and print and have the capacity to do so
yeah it's so interesting um all the bad um habits
that printing money incentivizes you know even as
simple as saving money like literally like what
is the point what is the point if it's gonna be
worth less tomorrow and i think what is such
a shame is that okay here's my thing i find it
you don't learn about finance in school like you
don't learn how to invest in the stock market um
like i only because of crypto do i understand the
stock market but i learned crypto first um and
i don't know what i would have done like what
would i have done i have no idea you know
what would i've invested in my money would
have just melted away um i was making money
when i was like 16 so you know i have enough
to want to make sure it doesn't lose value
and so for me i i'm just so grateful for bitcoin
and just all the opportunities for me i also say
that i kind of compare it to the american dream
like i know some people say the american dream is
dead but i feel it doesn't have to be dead and it
isn't necessarily dead because this is an entirely
new market um with so much opportunity whether
it's just to make money by investing or trading
but also in terms of jobs and there are so many
things for example check this out okay let's just
say you were doing a fight they say you're doing
a fight and um say you were fighting in london
i used to work for a local london television
channel and they probably that was when i was 21
they probably wouldn't have let me interview
you because i wasn't i don't know old enough or
experienced enough do you know what i mean there's
like hierarchies they probably wouldn't have left
me whereas like i don't [ __ ] work there anymore
i haven't worked there in years and like now you
and i can just have a chat and yeah that's for
me yeah yeah no i i i love that thought process
of like um and i saw my man i'm getting all kinds
of book recommendations another book that was just
recommended by my co-host jason williams was the
sovereign individual have you read that one yet
i haven't but a friend of mine just read
it and i didn't hear the best responses
um they said it was too focused on like um
the problem with money rather than bitcoin's
day-to-day application and cryptocurrencies
day-to-day application like how it can improve
your life that's what my friend told me i'll still
give it a read well the sovereign individuals
written in the in the mid 90s i believe yeah it
does kind of describe what bitcoin is going to
be but i mean to me what it really describes uh
and i guess the whole point of the premise of the
book is that there will be an end of the nation
state at some point because they're not providing
us the value that we're paying that right so what
we're paying them in taxes they're not providing
us equal value back um and that people will kind
of be more people will be doing their own thing
and bitcoin is going to allow us to do that
because we can just exchange currency between
you and i we don't have to go through uh you know
intermediary of the bank um and then obviously you
know like it kind of also goes to the point of um
what happened on only fans the other day oh my god
my life um but at the same point if people
want to have those type of things for a living
they can do those type of things and the bank or
the payment process is saying no you can't do that
right but with bitcoin that fixes that is people
can exchange money and that's the thing with all
these you know people are coming with the central
bank digital currencies and the government and
wallets and then they can you know stop spending
if you are who the hell was talking about
yesterday i was listening to someone i said yeah
if someone has a certain bmi they can block their
transactions at fast food restaurants or something
like that yes you can you can with those and so
just yeah so i guess i'm just going rifting
on your point about um having more freedom
uh i love freedom so more freedom between
it for individuals to do what they want
so i wasn't gonna ask you about this but like you
don't have to go into it um but what what's really
interesting and what i find in the cryptocurrency
industry particularly within the bitcoin movement
is everybody's got this um got very strong
libertarian undertones you know freedom
autonomy and we're always talking about this
bitcoin citadel um and i just read before
we've gone live so i'm sure i will get some awful
notifications i was just dealing with some trolls
um but delta airlines um have said that i'll
buy your post yes their unvaccinated employees
will have to pay two hundred dollars i mean i i
just wonder like there is that what they're doing
i don't know how they're gonna do it but yeah
essentially i don't know whether they'd get paid
the full amount then they have to pay it back
i don't know whether that's even legal because
basically that's medical discrimination but that's
happening anyway but what does it i mean how would
so i guess my question was how does delta even
have access because aren't there hipaa laws
which would prevent the company from
accessing your personal health information
yo you would think that's the case except as time
has gone on more companies are saying you can't
work here unless you're vaccinated so apparently
those human rights protections are no longer in
place i i don't know how companies are getting
away with it honestly um but i i wondered you know
whether you think given i think it kind of goes
hand in hand money printing inflation lockdowns
stimulus checks the whole thing for me personally
goes hand in hand i wonder whether you thought
we'd get to a point where we do break off you
know like the bitcoin citadel rises uh yeah i
i definitely see that as a possibility um and as i
read the sovereign individual it feels not like an
if but a when and so the simulator talks about you
know the transition so they talked about you know
um from how the church kind of ruled everything
for a long time to the transition to the nation
states the nation state in its current incarnation
has been around somewhere around 500 years um and
that we're going to move on to another phase uh
which the nation state goes away because they
don't provide the value so man i do think that's
going to happen uh the bitcoin citadel thing yeah
i have a hard time with that because if a major
world power really didn't want that to exist
i feel like they could somehow make that not
exist at this point in time right you know it's
some type of military intervention um obviously
you can't confiscate people's bitcoin because
it can be memorized i lost it i'm sorry i don't
have it anymore that you know i can't access
that so they can't actually steal your bitcoin
but they could you know if that nation state uh
say el salvador right if they become sort of
a bitcoin citadel there could be some type of
military intervention to change the government or
whatever um so i mean i would love for something
like that to happen because you what you what you
would have was a whole bunch of like-minded people
in this place who want to live their lives the
same way so i don't want to say it would be kind
of utopian but it feels like that but it also
feels like there's no way that's going to know
maybe it's florida and texas because they're
starting to drift further and further away from
the union yeah i think it is i think the whole
i think how life tends to work is that it's
never quite how you imagine so the citadel will
never be quite how we imagined but i i think it
could turn out to be florida and texas i mean
i think this conference i heard i mean i mean
i know this isn't like definite at all but i keep
hearing conversation of like florida breaking away
from the united states um but i mean yeah i don't
think that's serious at this point but yeah i mean
the way it's going it's i mean i say if florida
today said we're breaking away and we're acting
uh and the united states kept on the direction
it is like i would have to very strongly consider
moving to florida or texas it's hard it would be
very hard because i have my wrestling academies
i wouldn't be able to move those with me uh but
if we keep down the path that we're on uh less
freedom being poor printing more money obviously
those are all things that i don't really like
and do the do your like wrestling colleagues
i feel like i'm not using the correct words
um wrestling colleagues is that is that
well i have uh so obviously i have well i
have the people i coach with would be more like
colleagues right yeah and then i have you know
the wrestlers which i try as much as possible
they're 1800 most of them should never to get
into politics or that type of stuff with them uh
i try never to discuss that because i don't need
to be influenced that's what their parents are
for uh their parents but i'm not gonna talk to
them about governmental decisions and whatnot um
but yeah for my colleagues they they all know how
i feel most of them are like-minded that's why we
work together um yes they feel similarly that's
cool so so where are you where are you right
now you're on holiday uh we're i'm in northern
wisconsin so wisconsin's estate um it's so we were
about four hours so it's way up here there's just
a bunch of trees and lakes and not much else um
i'm actually i don't know if you ever heard of
disc golf but there's a disc golf course right
here so it's it's a great game i love it um so i
get to go and play every day and then we go to the
beach and we hang out and we do that type of thing
so it's really good oh my god that's the american
dream i'm telling you so what what what are your
final words where can people follow you what
are you up to um just show yourself for us ben
just it's just at ben askren everywhere uh twitter
instagram i don't really love instagram i post
it a little bit but i enjoy twitter i enjoy the
back and forth i enjoy the banter i enjoy reading
other people's opinions and thoughts i think
it's where the smartest uh dialogue happens
of any social media and dumbest no it's a great
club yeah i dare you to go read some instagram
comments and tell me twitter's the dumbest read
those instagram comments and you're like how is
anyone above 13 year old in these comments it
literally sounds like my three-year-old um yeah
yeah so then we do the funky crypto podcast on
tuesdays with jason i love your podcast by the
way i watch it all the time guys you need to watch
that podcast it's so funny you guys are just so
ridiculous um i really enjoy it so has added to
the ridiculousness factor because for he is very
highly intelligent but he is very goofy also yeah
no i think it's brilliant i think it's a great mix
i think that's how people should be i hate people
that are over that are super successful but are
so serious and you just can't have fun with
them that's that's never the way yeah but then
we'll have you on once your book drops and
we all read it we will have to come back on
and talk about it and then i'm actually going to
be in texas in uh september too so i know you i
saw you said that on twitter somewhere as well
yeah i will be yeah let me know it's probably
looking like october at this point but let me know
i'll be in texas thank you so much for coming on
say that sorry i keep i keep interrupting you
ben what did you say i said austin city austin
texas one of the greatest cities in america
you're gonna enjoy it is it or dallas i like
i prefer austin okay i heard it's full of
loads of liberals that's what i heard but
uh it's it you know what i so i i obviously uh
sorry we're trying to end the show and i'm talking
no go for it it's fine just go for it you know
what i i am like socially liberal like i don't
yeah a lot of things but in other ways i'm
conservative and so i think austin has that
good mix of there's certain liberal qualities
to it okay like the texas conservative feeling
as well so i really enjoy austin a lot what
about miami just last thought is it good
i haven't been to miami in a long time
but after i was so jealous i did not go
to the bitcoin convention i had something else
planned it was really stupid i should have went
um so it looked it looks so awesome
yeah i hope to go to the next one
that's the goal all right enjoy the rest of
your holiday thanks so much for coming on
i'm excited to come on to yours guys follow ben
check out his podcast it's actually hilarious
um and yeah that's it guys thanks so much for
watching and i will see you all next week bye